[Music]
take a look at this it's the olympic
torch making its way to the beijing
competitions they're already underweight
they're winter games but the opening
ceremony is tomorrow you know it's been
a very long road to the chinese capital
and no one knows that better than the
athletes and other people who are
attending the games like
tada or jamie yukas she has navigated a
strict and complicated bubble that china
put in place just for this pandemic so
she documented her stressful journey and
she says stressful is the word all the
way from l.a to beijing
the skies over beijing sparkling all
week with rehearsals of friday's opening
ceremonies the athletes are settling
into the village but also in the
starting blocks anxiety and covet
concern everyone headed to the games had
to make serious preparations i just got
to the testing center which is just
about a half mile from the airport we
have to get a test at 96 hours out and
72 hours out so this is my first of two
before i leave in a couple of days
getting to the games required a series
of invasive tests and two weeks of
health monitoring using a chinese
created mobile app
[Laughter]
not nice for me
the negative test results and other
health data had to be uploaded and
reviewed by chinese organizers i've got
all my health declarations and paperwork
negative tests
i am headed to air france finally
approved we could board our flights but
flights that were restricted to carry
only olympic participants and that would
deliver us directly into the beijing
bubble during a layover in paris we
bumped into nicole savera from brazil's
skeleton team the last two months
specifically i think have been even
harder just trying to
just hide from covid we knew we
qualified but we couldn't really
celebrate final passage a 10 hour flight
complete with onboard temperature checks
thank you
we just got off the plane we were
temperature checked on the plane we're
now going up
starting our series of procedures
airport greeters in full ppe garp
escorted us through a final series of
health checks and throat swabs
fail here and it could mean days of
isolation after two days of travel in
the home stretch waiting for our luggage
we met the jamaican bobsled team who
agreed it was an olympian effort just to
get on chinese soil i think i have to do
five tests before i could even get on
the plane so it was always like a real
tense moment you never know what the
outcome was going to be but now that
we're actually here it's absolutely
amazing the airport testing has proven
to be where most of the positive cases
have been detected
american bobsledder alana myers-taylor
was among those positive she's now
isolated from her one-year-old son who
traveled alongside her desperately
waiting to clear protocol people are
well spaced out dr brian mccloskey
chairs the medical panel advising the
beijing organizers he says it's a
three-tiered approach the testing
process gradually takes people out of
the system so the pre-departure testing
the airport testing and then the daily
testing in the closed loop at each of
those levels people who might becoming
infectious are identified so the time we
get the closed loop it's a very low
level of people testing positive the
closed loop aka the bubble secure buses
to and from venues and hotels plexiglas
between workspaces and dining tables
robots cleaning the floors
and serving meals no contact with anyone
from mainland china and yes more testing
every day
we're almost to china many athletes
consider it a win just to get past the
battery of tests and pre-games
challenges posting with pride i don't
like the tests anymore than i did the
first time but
we feel super safe here
just with all everything involving covet
and
at least i'm super grateful that these
games can still happen it's on to the
competition while organizers hope their
own olympic prep pays off on keeping the
bubble clean
talk about an anxiety-inducing trip i
really lived in my own bubble before the
journey keeping my distance from many
family and friends or making them keep
their distance from me i didn't even go
to the grocery store you guys it was
like march 2020 all over again and now
that we're in this beijing bubble where
many of us are using burner phones there
are several questions about how the
chinese may use all of the health and
personal data that's being collected
nate
jamie thank you so much so jamie as
you're sitting there going through all
of these tests do you feel like they
have everything in control or as much as
they can
i have to tell you now that we're in the
ground on the ground in the beijing
bubble i feel so much better i think i
felt so anxious i was so upset i had my
therapist cynthia on speed dial while i
was in the united states because there's
such a hodgepodge of rules now that
you're here you have to follow the rule
book everyone wears a mask there's the
plexiglass between everything we're
getting tested every day there is a
little bit of calm each day as those
tests come back and they're negative
i i can't wait to see the coverage jamie
i can't get over those deep dive nasal
swabs that they do you know that that's
like back old school where it feels like
it's hitting your brain a do you feel it
was worth it clearly i think you do and
i i can't wait to see your coverage
well thank you uh i i always go into
these assignments thinking in 10 years
will i look back and be upset if i
didn't go and so i'm glad to be here
it's a historic games uh you know
there's been many lead up to to what's
going to happen here i'm also excited to
see uh lots of the athletes as they
compete we're already seeing uh you know
them trying to get into some of the
competition we've got curling luge going
on women's hockey is about to start uh
so it should be really good games to
watch yeah good jammie i'm glad that
you're finally settled we had lunch
right before you left so it's i'm glad
that you're doing so we're doing good
jamie yukas in beijing we'll be right
back